in today's cloud minute I'm going to  show you how to view audit logs on  google cloud from the cloud console home  page click activity in the sidebar  now you can see all the activity on your  project you can use the filters to  restrict it to certain types of  activities such as jess configuration  changes  by default viewing data access logs is  turned off but you can turn it on here  to see the data access logs you'll need  the private logs viewer i am permission  you can also restrict your logs to just  a specific resource type like GCE VM  instances  or you can filter by email you can even  see audit logs across projects if you  need to audit logs can also be accessed  from stackdriver logging if you want to  create alerts based on certain  activities I hope this helps you keep  track of your system more efficiently